that there is a higher pay scale that
your pmp actually offers you uh moving
your career to the next level in fact
there is talented um over 17 percent um
that
you know you you tend to have even
higher uh when you have your pmp what
about your skills
you tend to gain knowledge to manage
projects better and of course this
aligns your skills with global best
practice
the identity you get in a formal display
of your professional ability your
profession you know you as a
professional as well as you know the
social rep you know reputation that that
it also gives you it also gives you your
necessary boosts
that your career needs and the
confidence that you actually portray as
a project manager and i think with these
glowing uh you know uh credentials uh
career-wise your skills and your
identity then there's value in actually
taking the pmp
um
i'm sure some of you will be able to
resonate with this um this man on the
screen
uh peter drucker uh a guru in the field
of management
but i just want to borrow lee from what
he said
with relating to choices um particularly
as relates to success in career he says
successful careers are not planned
they develop when people are prepared
for opportunities because they know
their strengths their method of work
their work values
now knowing where one belongs can
transform an ordinary person
hardworking
and competent but otherwise mediocre
into an outstanding performer and i
think this is this is very very useful
particularly when when we consider where
we are
um with our qualification now our
accreditation now on the pmp status
career-wise with the skills and the
identity
okay
so that's pretty druka for you um just
took this quote knowing fully well that
success in careers is not something you
sit down and you're saying okay this is
this this is all the plans yeah those
plans are good but of course you need to
get them into the development stage when
people are prepared you know for so it's
preparing yourself for the opportunities
because you know your strengths you know
where which are your you know strong
points and you know
your method of work and of course you
also have a value on yourself just like
you have a value and a qualification you
have that your pmp accords you
as you move or think about moving your
career to the next level i've looked at
this whole bit that i feel is quite
essential you know to moving your career
to the next level we've got to look at
goals you've got to look at your vision
let's consider your skills that you have
what about your interests what about the
values and of course essentially the
education and i think this is where the
pmp qualification or accreditation comes
into play because like i said haven't
gone through all the number of hours um
you want to actually see how do you
maintain how do you stay on top of the
game you know even as you align your
education with the goals and vision and
the values and the skills you've got
complementing that with your interest
moving to the next level of your career
i want to take a snapshot at you know
project management and professional
development
now
different people coming to project
management at different points at
different times
there are people who actually strayed
into the project management palace
okay so
perhaps that's you you may have been
introduced to project management
informally
or you may have come into project
management by virtue of the little
training you had
but whichever way you came into project
management i think we need to own our
professional development so there is an
aspect that relates to project
management itself but of course there is
an aspect that relates to how you
develop yourself professionally and
nobody and please i i say that with a
passion nobody can determine the height
and the depth of where you go
professionally other than yourself
so the development professionally will
include you know using the tools and the
skills related to project management you
know business and leadership now these
skills apply to projects
um and when i talk about projects we're
talking about unique delivery you know
it's time bound however their use goes
beyond that now if we're successful
in this profession
we can also be successful no matter what
we focus on because actually if you look
at it life or living itself is a project
on its own
so as a pmp uh
professional you want to actually see
you know from where we started from so
the road after pmp what's next for you
how do you maintain that accreditation
how do you maintain your professionalism
how do we move up the ladder you know on
the skills and the experiences remember
how do we move our career to the next
level how do we imbibe other skills you
know that attain to global best practice
and how do we actually ensure that we're
constantly boosting our self-confidence
as project managers
ultimately proving that success in our
career options
okay
what competencies do you actually reckon
that project managers need oh well i
i've put a put a slide in here that that
you know and i'm sure you can build more
on this uh project managers on a
day-to-day basis you know would need to
be planners you know they because uh
part of you know your work in project
management is planning so and i'm sure
with your pmp there's that element of
planning that comes into this
what about setting goals because we we
we have
have
we have target inside we have something
we want to achieve we have a product
that we want to deliver and as project
managers there is also the need to
communicate all this across stakeholders
both internal and external stakeholders
time and again project managers are
called upon to take judgments to make
you know uh judgment calls on on a few
and very important things which revolves
around decision making also
and as project managers because you're
not working on your own you're not
working in isolation there's a need to
actually ensure motivation motivation of
the resources at our disposal
so these core competencies i believe are
crucial if we're going to move down the
road um even with our pmp qualification
because you don't just want it to be
just um a certificate that you brand but
of course you want to be a certificate
that you um you know that will embellish
your planning your goal setting your
communication your judgment decision
making and ultimately motivated the
entire team
i i don't know if you can identify with
this
and maybe i'm sure you you could you can
pick up where you are um you know at any
point in time and this as a project
manager what do you do on a day-to-day
basis
well i love the one that talks about
drinking coffee yeah
i think a lot of project managers do
that yeah
project managers also uh you know apart
from that
i'm sure you you see quite a number of
them escalate yeah uh project managers
might even be involved in in motivating
in uh you know in encouraging people
in negotiating you know and in
celebrating okay um and i think this is
where we want to make sure that
everything we're doing with our pmp
revolves around the old days
um when i i don't know about you one
thing i've noticed is the project
managers also worry a lot
because because uh they're worrying
about you know will the project deliver
or how will it deliver will it meet to
the targets that have been set um and
and that's a crucial point because if it
fails uh or succeeds um you know their
career
is all is all um embedded on that
so how do we measure project success
um these are six aspects that i've
articulated that will and i'm sure you
can resonate with with this ones too in
your project management you know uh work
you've seen that well we need to keep an
eye on costs
the budget
we need to make sure that as project
managers success is based on how well we
can manage the risks what about the
quality of the products or the service
that we're delivering
in project management we hear a lot
about scope creep so if anything you
want to make sure that you know you're
keeping an eye so well on scope that
we're ensuring that we're not you know
having scope creep
what about the time that has been set
because remember time is not um
it's not it's a
it's a luxury you know within project
management we've got a project life
circle we've got a start and an end a
definitive start and a definitive end to
that project so we're making sure that
we're working within the boundary that
has been set on the time um i think if
you if you remember what i said in here
um i said um with with as it relates to
uh professional development these skills
apply to projects unique and they are
what they're time-bound so we're making
sure that we're keeping an eye on the
time and ultimately the the all essence
of doing this um as we walk down the
road with our pmp is that we can achieve
the benefits because all these
aspects of the project will determine
how successful or otherwise our project
is
we're managing
so what then do you consider as a
critical technical and soft skills which
are indeed indispensable for the modern
project manager like yourself i i've put
this in here which actually is an
offshoot from the project management um
institute the pmi you know
we need some element of you know this is
what we call pmi talent triangle so
you're looking at what level of of
leadership skills do you bring on board
how do you complement that with
strategic and business management and
how much of technical project management
skills can you actually embed into this
okay
there is a ccr which is a continuing
certification requirements program uh
and i'm going to talk about this as we
go on because these are skills that we
need to be building you know as we go on
so as a project manager i'll be
expecting some you know great level of
soft skills you know that come into play
remember what we said in here that you
know it's all about making sure as a
project manager you actually can
motivate now when you did your pmp i
believe maybe this was not a topic you
know that came in come into play but of
course you need to carry this into place
you want to actually
get people to deliver for you
okay
so uh with personal development and
career planning
the uptake is going to be that with your
pmp
there is a need to consciously develop
yourself
because if we don't do it what we're
going to get is that life itself will
shape us
and form our planning is the best chance
for developing
in the direction we desire so once we we
we have channeled ourselves that this is
where that you we've got to consider
where actually am i now and where do i
want to be in the next three years where
they want to be in the next five years
where they want to be in the next 10
years because remember this is a career
this is something that we want to build
on it's a road there's a long road you
know that we're trading on particularly
as we brandish our pmp accreditation
in fact uh one thing that you will find
um useful is that like i did say you
know when we started this beginning the
day that you pass your pmp exam
your pmp is active for a circle of three
years
and as a credential holder you must
obtain a total of 60 pdus known as you
know your professional development units
before the end of the cycle so before
the end of three years the expectation
is that at least you would have accrued
another 60 you know pdus else
you know uh you're suspended
your credential you know you suspended
for a period of one year so that's where
planning comes into play so for my
planning which is the best chance for
developing in the direction that we want
to go i'm going to articulate those
areas that will come you know useful as
we gather the pdus
and if anything um i did mention before
that project management actually uh you
know our daily living is project
management on its own so what what works
in business works in our lives we should
use our skills for personal growth you
know we should look at what are the
the strengths you know according to
peter drucker what he says is that when
they using the feedback analysis what
printed druka you know the great uh
management the expert said is that we
should concentrate on our strengths we
should improve our strengths we should
discover and overcome disabling
ignorance so brightness is not an excuse
for lack of knowledge
so career planning is nothing more than
another project so
and this is how we need to
you know how seriously we need to take
our career planning you know options so
it's it's it's
a form of project itself you can look at
it as a program you can look at some
pasta portfolio um it isn't a great
opportunity to use a skill um you know
for a benefit yeah
okay
so
let's look at more questions than
answers and i'm sure some of these
things you you'll be able to resonate to
it um
so you might be at a point where you're
asking yourself oh well you know what
i need 60 pdus to renew my pmp
and your question to me might be do you
know how to end the pdus oh well i will
try and point you in some direction uh
what about the pdu categories
because
to some of us it looks quite complicated
so
um do you know what are the pdu
qualified activities what do i do
because that articulating those
activities you know are quite crucial
you know to continue in uh um
professional and at some events and that
are ordered pdus do you know how to
report them on pmi yeah and we're going
to also look at that as we as we delve
into into some of those things
so let's take this first one first how
do we actually earn pdus oh well
i it's it's i i love if you look at my
my blend of of apples here i mean it's
your peak
so you can use continuous learning by
attending project management courses
you can also reference these by reading
project management books you can
contribute to the community you can
volunteer service you know for the pmi
um you can auto for project management
article in a journal um and of course
you can be and all all i'm trying to say
is this that there are so many things
that can be done to actually end your
pdu so but what i find out you know from
experience is that a lot of people just
focus on one aspect but you've got to
look at different areas and different
aspects that will accrue again remember
ultimately what we're trying to do is
ensure we break that 60 or 60 pdu units
or more
let's look a little bit at the
categories you've got category a you've
got category b you've got category c and
these three categories actually fall
under what i would refer to as the
education category so you can use any of
this category where okay well it's
either through continuing education is
either through self-directing or exactly
to component courses that you're taking
to actually make sure that you you
acquire you know units in here you could
also use category d category d uh e and
category f uh category d which is
creating new project management
knowledge okay uh you can also offer
your services volunteer services you
know and accrue some pdu on that or even
professional uh be a professional in
project management you know so you give
back to the professional you know
category community uh in that category
itself
so any of this structure will come
useful so you can acquire points so you
can occur units um either on the
educational category or giving back to
the profession category
okay let's consider a few might here so
there's one in here that says i need to
maintain 90 pdus if i have a pmp and pmp
rmp credentials okay um the the the uh
rm oh sorry about that the rmp
credentials is a risk management
professional so you might you might um
be one that's already got this um and of
course you well the bonus is that no you
can earn pdus toward maintaining pmi
credentials you know simultaneously now
if you have a pmp or you have a pm pmi
rmp that is the risk managing
professional now you find the event that
provides pdus um to put credentials
that's that's that's that's what you
need to do and of course you and your
pdus
okay
um what about
attending courses because um
i think this is one area that a lot of
people you know find that there are
going to be 1001 courses that you find
out there and you would appreciate the
fact that this is where simply learn
comes you know quite useful because then
for each of the courses that you attend
you're already told what pdus you
actually can accrue you know with that
so courses offered by raps are
recognized by pmi and can provide you
pdus so you can also end pdus by
attending non-rp courses but if you are
audited you need to justify the number
of hours for pdu in the case of non-irp
courses so i'm saying yes you can still
attend non-rp courses but i think
you know to a great extent the number of
rep courses you know out there that you
can attend and you can always troll
looking at what simply then offers um
you know to actually acquire some points
um
this is also what my the cost providers
told me i can earn um
some numbers of pdus i can take that and
so many pdus based on one r is equal to
one pdu now what you need to be careful
of is this if the cost provider is
non-rap
and simply land does not fall into that
category happily now it is the
responsibility of pmp to gauge whether a
course is relevant to the knowledge or
process areas as listed within pmbok
guide
so i i think for anybody who is going to
be attending any of the courses what you
want to actually find out is are these
reps or not
okay what if i have more than 60 pdus in
my current um ccr okay circle and
remember the ccr is what i said um you
know is your your uh your three years um
that you've got uh i can carry forward
the extra in excess of 60 pdus to the
next year oh yes you can that's correct
so because i mean if for example within
three years you've accrued maybe 80 or
90 or 100 pdus all you need for that
current
circle it's just the um
it's a 60 units and of course you can
carry you can roll over the other one or
about how big to a maximum of 20 pdus to
the next ccr circle
and these pdus must be end in the third
year of the current circle so you you
want to make sure that that is current
so it's just making sure that you take
note of that
okay
i did mention this before uh somebody
asked a question
must i take my pmp exam if i do not
obtain 60 pdus at the end of the last um
ccr cycle oh yeah if your pmp has lapsed
for more than one year yes
so that's why it's important that you
make sure that um your certification
does not lapse okay um and if it does
you want to make sure that it's uh you
you you release it from the suspension
that it is within that one year okay but
if you fail to re-satisfy and still
within a year of the xperia pawn then
your pmp status will be
will be in suspension and like i said
before
um this means that the individual is no
longer considered to be a pmp and they
must retake the exam to actually
re-certify
okay let's consider some courses i i i
want to mention this area because one
thing
in fact a number of us do not know that
even taking courses in microsoft project
accrues
you know pdus for us
so
taking a basic course say for example
you're running a session on microsoft
project 2010 or you know 2013 you know
it even gives you you remember i did
categorize this and let me just quickly
flash this back you know where i was
talking about the education category now
this is where continued education comes
into play because then actually
even you know taking this course itself
can accrue between 30 to 60 pdus for you
taking a microsoft project
2010 you know cost
so
in you can end 60 pdu's in that category
b to renew and keep your pmp
certification and learn how to master
powerful project management tools so
using the tools you know actually come
come quite useful
but remember when you're doing when
you're taking the course make sure
you're doing it um
it uh with that accreditation um in
place
okay
critical technical and soft skills that
are indispensable for the modern project
manager like yourself
uh i've categorized it in three areas uh
pm good
uh so project management good practices
want to enhance your performance by
maintaining your projects on track on
time and within your project by
leveraging a powerful capabilities of
say for example ms project you want to
manage multiple tasks complex workbook
breakdown structures evolving you know
schedules and resolving you know
critical allocations of course you can
also consider strategic business options
so developing awareness of what project
management software can and cannot do
for your organization so you know you
consider strategies to utilize best
software features to perform the
budgeting the forecasting
uh you know and other things that goes
with it how about your leadership you
know skills you know building on those
to actually see how you can lead a team
how you can get them you know you leave
your team to complete tasks
by utilizing the software that will help
to resolve problems and communicate
effectively in a complex business
environment and all these can accrue
to your professional development units
and i'll say don't wait until last
minute because a number of people do
that and of course at the last minute
you're just scrambling to see what you
can what you can actually put together
what what what um and and that is where
i say um but for your pmp
re-certification
um it's a project you want to take it as
it is uh you look at your scope what are
the requirements you want to achieve
your 60 pdus and there is a cons a time
constraint also you know in occurring
that 60 pdu's it's going to be accrued
within three years which is at six
months
um
what about a cost implication well i'll
leave that to you to actually work out
and other people might also look at you
know other ancillary courses you know
like i did mention look at courses in
risk management courses in quality
management um
is this 60 pde is difficult to obtain
maybe not i would say
how do you plan your study for your pmp
exam you need a plan
for your study also for your pdu also so
and you keep your records because that's
going to come quite um quite useful so
remember to keep your record for the pdu
remember when we started we're looking
at what's going to happen what's the
road after pmp okay you want to make
sure that your you know maintain so upon
claiming uh your 60 pdu's and paying
your renewal fees of course your
three-year circle begins again but keep
your records because that's quite useful
okay briefly let's look at the
leadership and interpersonal skills that
you need to actually make sure that you
move your career in the right direction
interpersonal skills are needed
uh by project managers and and i've i
have highlighted a few of them in here
because remember when i you know
mentioned what are the things that
project managers do i didn't mention
things like even motivating so we need
some element of leadership
we need to to gain some credence in team
building what about motivation uh
project managers need to also imbibe
some element of communication we need to
be to be able to influence you know
decisions um and political and cultural
awareness you cannot stay alone you need
to also as a project managers your pmp
you know following from your pmp um
develop some skills relating to
negotiating
and if anything if anybody is going to
believe you
and your credibility i i think they need
to believe on your trust you need to
start building trusts okay project
managers also need some element of
conflict management okay because
remember within the the project you're
managing you're going to be different
dynamics
some different conflicts you know um
within different people many different
different stakeholders but of course
that's stepping in and using your
people's skills to actually manage such
conflicts
i would also see uh one of the you know
essential skills for a project manager
is is ensuring that he or she is
actually a coach so taking on coaching
um and and if possible mentoring to
actually build capacity within the team
well so what's the need you want to make
sure that you're tracking your
professional development and continued
education of the pmi um credential
holders you may be meet the requirements
of the pmi creation of recertification
on a three-year circle
um i just if you log on into your
dashboard
you will see that this is where you can
view your pde reports okay and of course
you can earn pdus
in this place so if you go into your
your login details just like i've shown
you on this one here
you can view
the pdus report and of course you can
also end pdu's in there
for your continued certification
requirement system which is also on the
side um certainly you can look at the
ccrs
pmi.org and of course you can see what
are the continuing certification
requirements um that can be recorded on
them this is where everything is done
and of course audited accordingly
okay for the credentials for the
continuous certification requirements
okay it's more of going into the uh the
toolbar where you have credentials and
certification and of course like i did
mention all the different categories you
have um so if it's something you want to
record under category a um a registered
education provider pm pmi component or
is a continuing education category c
your self-directed learning which you
can all record um that's where to go um
and of course you can also record you
know other activities i've given you an
example of what we're doing in here so
for example if you're on the go go a
program um
via simply land this is where you go
and of course you record that and of
course you look at the provider name and
record the activity
so you can select the the from the
mirage of activities that you have in
there um and of course um update your
your details you can report your your
pdu so this is the other example when i
was given about you know even taking a
course say for example in microsoft
project on 2010 you can you know record
that and of course that can be verified
by um
by the project management institute and
once the verification is done what you
would expect is that they will send you
an acknowledgement um which will come in
format of an email okay so there's an
acknowledged email that you get okay
which claim has been submitted and once
that has been approved you're gonna get
an approval email from there to say yes
we've approved um what what you've done
but i keep saying that you just want to
make sure that all your records are in
place
okay
so um going on from what we said about
those skill sets
let's look at you know the plan they do
the check and the act so you identify an
opportunity and you plan for change you
implement so in doing it you implement
the change on a small scale you use the
data to analyze the change you determine
whether it made a difference and you
successfully implement on a wider scale
if not you begin the circle again i i i
very much believe in the in the pdca the
plan do um check and act um syndrome by
them
okay so that's that for me um is is how
to how to build uh on your career in
project management um
and say so you can see in here um the
way to climb the ladder
okay you need to determine what are you
doing in the first one to five years
what are you doing in the next five to
ten years what about ten years plus okay
and the what's going to be the uptake is
you know are looking at business
management or you want to consider
project management okay you want to look
at technology are you going to be
technology focused because some of us
come from the i.t background where we're
all we want to just think about is the
hardware the software the security the
backup yeah there's an opportunity for
that or you want to actually just
consider the business side um you know
things
okay and there are some courses some
ancillary courses that you're going to
find useful um i did mention the uh this
is the pmp the pmi uh vehicles which
which can also come as a complement to
what you do in project management so and
i'm sure some of you must have had about
six sigma or the lean um and think about
things like agile
okay they all this come into play
because then you want to position
position yourself either as a generalist
or as a technical manager
okay all of us cannot be generalists
neither can all of us be technical
project managers so we just want
to make sure that we are one of um of
whatever we're doing at any point in
time okay
right so i did mention in here that you
can also take on the uh the service
option service delivery option that is
where the itil comes into play the
information technology infrastructure
library which uh
focuses on continuous service
improvement okay so you're looking at
service design you're looking at
transition uh service transition you're
looking at service operation and
building service strategy and you'll see
a lot of id delivery
particularly
system support
help desk services
using the itrl the information
technology infrastructure library system
and that is something you can also blend
with your pmp
okay what about the cm mi
uh for those of you who might be
thinking of well okay i actually don't
want to you know focus on the i.t side
of things then of course you can
actually be looking at quality so the
capability maturity model integration is
a proven industry um it's a proven
industry uh framework that improve
product quality and of course
development of efficiency for both
hardware and software okay you've got uh
five levels and it describes the
maturity and you know this is another
another aspect that you can look into to
actually blend with your pmp
certification
so the cm mi capability maturity model
integration framework
what about you working as a pmo well uh
let me let me go back a little bit here
because you can see here i said you you
can actually move your career even
if you're not moving on the general side
on the technical side you can actually
move into the pmo the project management
office now that is where what you're
doing is actually working on policies
you're you're you're building you know
training structure you're looking at
resourcing for the project or programs
you're actually helping them with
processes you are helping them with
standards or standardization and helping
them with governance
and and people a lot of people who
actually coming from the ad meaning
admin uh um side of things you know will
find the pmo um you know quite useful so
you can align your pmp to actually make
sure that you can actually build
capability for yourself
even in the project management office
side of things you know with policies
with training with support and
resourcing
processes and standardization
here again i did mention the six sigma
okay as something that you can look into
apart from the business analysis you
know side of things and an area that
will come useful is actually when you
look at the um lean six sigma green belt
certification what we refer to as a ls
sgb the lean six sigma green belt
excuse me
beyond the c six belt your um the green
belt you've got the black belt
but but at least the grim belt gives you
um you know a leverage where you can
work not just as as
a project person you know with your pmp
accreditation but also moving
in line of process optimization
oh how about uh agility as a project
manager okay and i'm sure a number of
you must have heard of agile so what is
uh how does how does this come to play
now agile was developed by a group of
software developers um remember agile is
not a method but it can be combined with
methods you know so the methods such
like scrum so working as an agile
project manager is actually imbibing one
of these other things or one of these
other methods you know just like um your
scrum your kanban you know come into
play so again requires a single working
team okay so it's quite different from
the traditional way you know that you
work as a project manager and of course
it relies on frequent face-to-face
communication uh wherever possible
and of course with
encourages developers and users to work
very closely together a lot of people
think agile is actually just tied into
the software side of things but i i bet
to say that you see with the word
agility it's actually seen how can we
get things done so it's not just it's
not just about software is actually more
about solutions
okay so project management skills as
influencers what do you need you need
technical skills so accurate estimation
are predictable controls guaranteed
results you need some level of business
skills okay uh being able to align with
how companies do their business so
okay so you've got some level of
business acumen that comes into play uh
proving decision making proving growth
how about your leadership skills you
know motivation like i did mention
conflict resolution increased level of
performance these are some core skills
that you need to start thinking of after
your pdu i'm sorry after your pmp
certification and looking at skills even
as you complement and move on with your
pdu
okay
market trends
i'm sure one of the things i did mention
before was the fact that um if you
remember i said uh that there is a
search that has gone into play that your
certification as pmp holder you know
actually moves you 70 plus 17
higher you know uh i'm sorry why so uh
and i've tried to do an analysis here
where you look at professionals either
um
pmp or prince2 um if you've done this
course and of course you've got your
microsoft project and play uh you know
your salary you know range that you
could be looking at you know um either
the job market and the uk job market or
even in the indian market um you know
it's just mind-blowing it's just
mind-blowing i can complement that you
know like i said also with looking at
you know your pmp qualification and you
imbibe that with your quality management
you know the cmmi or you're looking at
some six sigma uh the grim bells or
you're looking at the pmp or the you
know and looking at how you can
complement that with agile you know
framework or the um service um
optimization or service delivery that
comes in with itil or you can actually
even put your pmp with your microsoft
project or your uh managing successful
programs i mean they they you can see
that the great variety that you have um
and and the great um opportunities that
are bound you know salary wise it's all
there it's it's all it's a win-win
situation always on the high okay and
that is where i think your certification
um comes useful again the job role and
the skills so the pmp and the six sigma
so you can do i have a combination so
don't just stay on your pmp you want to
think of the next step you remember what
we said looking at where are you in the
next five years where are you in the
next 10 years where you be on 10 years
so that's where you're looking at okay
where do you want to align your skills
is it going to be in the build of
quality quality management okay so if
that's going to be the case then why
don't you look at your pmp and six sigma
okay you could also think of well okay
you want to build on pmp which you
currently have looking at six sigma to
actually improve quality and yet you're
looking at itil which is it service you
know because you want to you're actually
looking at the service industry
on itself the it service industry okay
and beyond that um you want to also look
at you remember i mentioned
the
pmp your itil so you can
okay um
simplyland now has a program which you
call the complete project management
expat you know program that involves or
you know it combines your pmp
certification with your itil with your
linseek sigma grim belt and of course
with the accredited um service manager
uh um offering that you have the
complete package of skills to be an
expat of of the domain you know that
you're coming
the agile certification is extremely
vital for all project managers that is
the future of project management and i'm
sure you've noticed that now that almost
in everything you're doing you're
hearing the vibe which is agile agile
and agile in fact the interested i said
yesterday i went to a seminar yesterday
and and then gave um
gave an introduction um into uh
agile for project for pmos
okay um so that it will include uh you
working in different variants of of um
whether it's lean or kanban or crystal
or scrum and of course as application
across different different industries
because this is not localized to a
particular industry he actually works
across different industries as a
complete person
so the coincident uh pillars for project
management revolves around you know
ensuring that not not only are you
brandishing your pmp please remember
please add things relating to quality
management relating to you know the
software itself how about your itil how
about your agile there is something in
need for every one of us whether you
want to look at the technical side of
things or you want to look at the
administrative side of things
career opportunities endless ideas
project analysts project coordinators
project managers i.t project managers
construction project managers finance
projects managers pmos and the like
working in the bank working in in the
real industry working in construction
working in manufacturing
let's be let's be honest with ourselves
the certification you have is a golden
ticket that opens your horizon to work
across different sectors
call to action
so if you ask me
what do i do now
so that's my question for you so what
are you gonna do now
okay
you got to stop thinking
where are you going to be in the next
five years
what are you achieving so that's why i
go back again to that my plan
you know uh um
you know so you plan with it with a
distinct goal in mind you build a deming
uh um and a druka uh uh you know uh
feedback system in place then you build
your infrastructure okay uh i is either
you want to be a broad generalist okay
or you want to focus on your deep skills
or you want to embark on crazy big deep
skills okay um you know which is which
is actually focusing on your strengths
or you want to fine-tune and evaluate
you know continue to redefine
add new you know where it builds and
success ad where it keeps um away from
failure
i've said
your choice
ultimately what the question you need to
be asking yourself is what's in it for
me
you determine where you sit on this
you pick your six
but it's all gonna be about your choice
but
perhaps i want to say this you might be
a little bit selfish about that choice
asking yourself
what's in it for me
thank you
i hope at least um this has been an
eye-opener um ensuring that at least you
can see what
the roadmap
is after pmp
considering the pdus and of course the
skills that we take you ahead in your
career
richard
thanks thank you thank you um i'm going
to take over the screen for just a
minute while we start over start to
start over while we start the question
and answer part
and then i'll also take the first
question since it's something that's on
my side uh so let me go ahead and just
take over we're going to launch a poll
over the screen
uh and so the one of the questions that
comes up is will this webinar be
available later for on-demand viewing
from
yes
the presentation they do record it and i
have to apologize because i did not hit
the record button or start recording at
the very beginning so the first five
minutes is chopped off
yeah so that was all on me someone
caught that back in the office uh but it
is on recording what you'll do is you'll
go to simply learn go under the support
and just send them a request for the um
a copy of this and they'll send you the
link for that
the presentation itself we don't send it
out in pdf format sorry about that
you have to actually download the view
because it changes
it certainly changes and it's always
growing
there's always something new in the
field
let's see while we're going here i have
a question
from ken
do you earn pdus by performing your
daily work job duties how does that work
oh yes
thank you very much ken for that
question
yes you do
because
and i'm quickly just going to trick you
back in here recall i talked about
uh your pdu categories
okay
your category a which i said is your
component courses
may be obtained through courses offered
by registered
educational providers uh category b may
be obtained through courses offered by
the university or college uh category c
uh of
10 through self-study such as reading
books and magazines but when you now
look at your category e
um they end by volunteering in pmi
f and simply by being a project manager
professional so you
you know it all depends on what what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis and
of course so
your pdus are end simply by being a
project manager professional or
practitioner
that's right all you have to do is
manage projects to unlimit or five pdus
per year or 15 pdus per three
excellent okay so so so it does
then you have to keep that recorded
there was a question on
uh let's see where's rohan or john which
books can i read to earn pdus is there
is there certain books or something else
in your own
personal study that you can do to earn
pdus
and if so how does that work
okay um if you if you look at pattern
d waste has created a new um
body of knowledge the videos maybe end
by altering or presenting publications
publications presentations and trainings
that contribute to the project
management body of knowledge um this can
include articles books blogs webinars
the list is endless let's let's be
realistic because if you look at it um
there is no particular as long as it as
long as the book you're reading relates
to any of those um core areas that the
pmp the pmbok you know actually promotes
um you you're you're good to go on that
i did mention even you're taking uh
microsoft project as a course and of
course that crowd accrues you know up to
30 pdus actually for you so um
there is no specific book um recommended
to read it's it's just and of course on
the pmi website also
there are loads of of resources
available for you to reach actually and
pdus
oh excellent
great great resource on there for if you
love to read i know i love a good book
kicking back and
find someplace quiet to sit down and
read
we have a lot of people asking
can attending this webinar earn pdus
okay we'll we'll pass that question to
simply learn
but remember what we said remember what
we said category d
um ensures that you can also earn um
pdus by attending webinars so um let's
let's pack that to to um
to simply learn and
um find out how many pdus can be earned
you know earning um
by participating in a webinar yeah and i
i really don't know if you go to the
simply learn um
support page you might be able to send
them a note and then if it is something
they can send you like some kind of
confirmation or something like that that
you were here yeah i honestly don't know
i'm going to have to ask on that one
yeah i think we need to do it
um let's see who's going to attend
and then
just going down the list here so there
was a whole section on volunteering
which i thought was really neat i know
in
our community that i'm in i'm an active
uh very active member of the startup
community here my in our town and they
had a startup show and i think they had
160 hours worth of volunteers doing
mentoring
and
free sessions and training which i
thought was really neat
can you give other examples on volunteer
work and how that what that looks like
so i know you're involved in some of
that in your area too
oh yes
excuse me
um on the
pmi
uh
website itself
you've got a whole chunk that even
allows you
um
if you go in there there's a whole chunk
that says pmi um dot org front slash
memberships front slash volunteer
opportunities so with the pmi itself you
actually can even get volunteer
opportunities there for you you know
where you can actually
make an impact uh currently you've got
volunteer opportunities for region
mentors for member advisory group for
standard committees
exam development volunteers i mean that
whole list you know or volunteering
opportunities but apart from that
there are also volunteer opportunities
within the
within wherever you you're located i
mean i stumbled on one which was uh
i i'll give you an example there's this
one that is a pmi i don't know if you're
in the um in the indian region
there's a pmi karachi pakistan chapter
okay
um it's a non it's a volunteer
non-profit organizations volunteers are
cornerstone to the foundation of that
chapter you know you have different
chapters and of course what they do is
actually bring up different programs um
and of course they've got you know
you've got a structure in place for each
of these chapters um there are loads of
them in the us um that i'm aware of that
you know run different sessions even for
youths um and
you know that's that
the the list of volunteer opportunities
uh is endless it's endless and of course
you can um
you can make make do over of it and you
can earn your pdus like we said you can
end all project managers certified by
project manager professionals and pmps
uh by the project management institute
are required to earn a total of 60
professional units like we said every
three years and you're volunteering is a
very good way where you're giving back
to the to the um to the profession
excellent oh great great sources on
there um that is excellent
uh we are getting down to the end of the
time period uh do you have any last
words of um advice to give before we go
ahead and sign off
okay maybe the other thing i could
mention is that actually uh you could
earn after 20 pdus
even as a volunteer
so it's just looking at the areas you
know where you you actually can can
support that local
local place and of course see how you
can you can contribute back to the
community and that's that's a great way
to actually do it yeah
excellent
all right well we look forward to seeing
uh everyone thank you for being here we
look forward to seeing you in our simply
learn classrooms
uh my name is richard and this is odu
who had a wonderful presentation i
always enjoy working with olu
and we wish you guys a here welcome a
good morning good afternoon or good
evening and happy learning
thank you very much
excellent all right bye bye and have a
great day
you